[Musique]
Hélène buzetti Michel Surget Méline
bonsoir bonsoir
alors session parlementaire à Québec
éclaire on en parlera tout à l'heure sur
le contenu on sait déjà quel projet de
loi seront présentés mais d'abord le sur
la c'est de la cuisine mais en même
temps c'est important parce qu'on en
parle depuis la soirée électorale de la
représentativité est-ce qu'on peut
pallier à notre système électoral
qui revient à la charge
m'avait oublié moi là vous parlez
beaucoup du Parti québécois mais moi je
demande d'avoir un bureau je demande
d'avoir que je puisse faire des points
de presse à l'Assemblée nationale même
si je n'ai pas de député on va écouter
monsieur Duhem et le Parti québécois qui
appuie monsieur Duhem puis on revient
ce qu'on demande essentiellement c'est
ce que j'avais déjà avant le 3 octobre
j'avais réussi à convaincre une seule
personne une seule femme classe ensemble
de joindre le Parti conservateur du
Québec qu'on avait tous ces privilèges
là aujourd'hui on a convaincu 530 000
personnes de voter pour nous puis on a
même plus droit de rentrer dans
l'Assemblée nationale il y a quelque
chose qui a aucun sens c'est réglement
long été fait à une époque où il y avait
deux parties aujourd'hui en 5
mais la même façon si on a eu obtenu
4.6% des suffrages puis un autre parti
conservateur avec lequel sur le plan
idéologique on a pu en commun mais qui a
quand même été chercher 13 % des voix en
toute cohérence il faut qu'ils aient
aussi le moyen de porter cette voie là à
l'Assemblée nationale
bon Hélène on est en train d'essayer de
trouver des solutions un système qui a
créé des distorsions là
oui puis il y a deux éléments le côté
conservateur était un peu différent
parce que on demande essentiellement
l'accès à un micro à l'intérieur plutôt
qu'à l'extérieur ça peut être pas la
même impact que les demandes plus vaste
financières et de ressources du Parti
québécois je comprends la frustration
qui découle des proportions disparité
que qu'ogénérée le processus électoral
mais il y a quand même me semble-t-il un
certain risque en vouloir utiliser des
normes administratives pour essayer de
contourner ou de rectifier un résultat
électoral qui nous apparaît
absurde ou en tout cas ne reflètent pas
leur volonté de la population je
comprends cette volonté mais se faisant
il y a quand même on a quand même pour
effet de venir un peu saper la
légitimité du processus électoral et ça
vient et blanc aller la confiance des
citoyens je pense dans nos institutions
ultimement si on n'aime pas ce ce
processus électoral
[Musique]
déco il produit voilà et ben
changeons-le je suis pas nécessairement
en faveur moi d'une réforme électorale
mais ça c'est pas important ayant ce
débat et décidons de le changer ou pas
mais d'utiliser les règles
administratives pour le contourner peut
avoir pour effet débranler encore plus
la confiance des citoyens dans leur
système électoral et ça c'est pas
positif me semble-t-il ouais Michel
c'est Auger jusqu'où ce que pose Hélène
comme question jusqu'où on peut aménager
le règlementaire pour contrebalancer une
distorsion ou en tout cas qui le
pourcentage du vote n'est qui va il n'y
a pas un rapport direct le nombre de
députés on a compris ça
[Musique]
mais le règlement était justement de
pallier jusqu'à un certain point les
urbes dire la base c'est c'est douche
députés ou 20% à l'époque c'est possible
que quand il y avait trois parties
maintenant c'est plus vrai mais juste
Michel pour être sûr pour ce qui est
duem vous dites le seuil c'est d'avoir
au moins député en bas de ce seuil là en
bas de ce seuil là vous êtes vous êtes
pas parlé alors vous êtes il y a pas de
négociation à y avoir même si en
pourcentage j'ai collé sur le PQ mais il
a accès comme citoyen à la tribu de la
presse de presse là l'autre bord de la
rue c'est l'autre côté de la rue ça il
peut faire ça
il y a plein de choses qui peuvent faire
alors il se plaît beaucoup le ventre
plein là surtout qu'il reçoit comme
partie ayant reçu des voies à
l'Assemblée alors
Émilie mais j'allais justement dire une
chance qu'il y a eu une réforme du mode
de financement des partis politiques
parce que ça pallie un peu à la question
de l'argent qui est vraiment le nord de
la guerre en ce moment dans les débats
qu'on a si il y a une distorsion entre
le nombre de votes et le nombre de
députés à l'Assemblée nationale au moins
il y a moins d'importance entre le
nombre de votes et le financement des
partis politiques et je pense que c'est
ça qui va faire une différence pour
quelqu'un comme irréductuel mais
certainement pour la partie québécois
aussi dans les prochaines années c'est
que oui au niveau du temps d'antenne à
l'Assemblée nationale ou ou de l'accès
par exemple un parti conservateur
à l'édifice comme test c'est plus
compliqué mais il y a d'autres choses
sur lesquelles sur ton sur ton je vais
être d'accord avec tout le monde c'est
que on est en train d'essayer d'avoir le
dépôt sur la réforme du mode de scrutin
sans parler de la réforme du mode de
scrutin et c'est là qu'on fait un peu
les choses à l'envers et je pense que ce
serait important d'avoir ce débat on le
dit après l'élection mais c'est comme
s'il est en éclatant peut fermer la
porte les parties les parties de
position essaient d'avoir ce débat là
autrement je pense toutefois que le en
fait le fait d'avoir fermé la porte la
réforme du mode discuter en disant les
gens ont la tête ailleurs ça fonctionne
pas si ça crée toutes ces chicanes là
l'Assemblée nationale toutes ces
complications là à l'Assemblée nationale
ça va peut-être contribuer à remettre ce
débat qui est le débattement qu'on
devrait avoir vraiment sur le sur le sur
le devant au moins ne serait-ce que du
débat public ni si ce n'est pas des
priorités d'acaques ouais mais pas sûr
Hélène qu'on le débat va vraiment être
lancé à partir du moment où le joueur
principal dit il y en a pas question
non exactement ça aura pas lieu et même
si ça avait lieu je vous l'ai dit moi je
suis un peu sceptique je me disais un
peu sceptique ne serait-ce que pour ce
que j'ai vu récemment à Ottawa quand on
a eu aussi des vérités de réforme en
2016 le problème c'est que s'il y a une
majorité de gens qui disent ne plus
aimer le système actuel c'est que cette
majorité ne sera pas unanimement
derrière un système alternatif une fois
qu'on dit qu'on n'aime pas le système
après les gens se distribuent derrière
toutes sortes de formules et je me sens
je me souviens qu'à Ottawa même le petit
comité réduit d'une douzaine de
personnes représentant chacun chacune
des formations politiques qui avaient
étudié cette question entendu tous les
spécialistes tout ce qu'elle avait
réussi à
générer comme conclusion c'était
rappelez-vous une formule mathématique
formule mathématique par laquelle on
était supposé d'évaluer le niveau de
représentativité sur lequel déboucherait
l'un ou l'autre des modes de scrutin
qu'on envisagerait et on disait au
gouvernement essayer de trouver une
formule là qui qui obtiendra avec la
formule mathématique entre tel chiffre
et tel chiffre évidemment le
gouvernement c'était empressé d'utiliser
ça pour railler tout le processus et le
mettre au vidange mais ça démontre la
difficulté de s'entendre sur une
solution de rechange ok c'est pas si
simple et voilà
l'autre question parce que le Parti
québécois a gagné un peu de de temps de
parole de questions je sais pas si on a
le tableau normalement très vendredi
quand finalement la négociation a pris
fin le Parti québécois aura un certain
nombre de questions par mois par 7% des
questions deux questions par semaine
budget de 570 000 donc c'est plus
qu'actuellement un siège d'observateur
au bureau de l'Assemblée nationale là la
question c'est avec ceci en poche
vont-ils entrer oui on revient au
serment du roi parce que c'est demain
s'ils veulent entrer demain pour élire
la présidente l'Assemblée nationale ils
doivent prêter serment s'ils prêtent pas
serment ils rentrent pas que feront-ils
on va écouter monsieur arsenault
mais moi je dirais que comme député là
on pense qu'on a toute la légitimité
pour représenter les citoyens des mardi
à l'Assemblée nationale comme député on
a aussi dit qu'on se tiendrait debout
devant un certain nombre d'éléments de
conjugés inéquitable ou qui sont
archaïques comme le comme le serment et
on va s'assumer
bon on va s'assumer Michel C
donc il rentre pas demain c'est où il
rentre une personne rentre
en 70 par exemple on devait laisser une
personne dehors
cette député là n'est pas entré pour
dire tout est pas correct ici là mais à
un moment donné je l'avais dit de
rentrer là j'ai payé pour faire ce
travail là pour rester dans mais
c'est vrai que cette affaire-là est
accueillique en même temps c'est une
formalité ils sont en fait ils sont
vraiment perturbés dans un coin avec sa
faire là je dis quand même
parjure c'est René Lévesque c'est par
jury Jacques Parisot c'est par juré
Louis Philippe Le Louis
Papineau c'est par jury à l'époque
Joseph
et je pense que le temps est venu d'en
revenir parce que vous êtes le réel
devrait les faire rentrer en même temps
je vais vous montrer le calendrier
Hélène Émilie il y a pas beaucoup de
jours il y a 8 jours de session est-ce
que ils vont laisser le du projet de loi
pour annuler ou rendre optionnel le
serment du roi puis vont rentrer fin
janvier ou ou mais il y a 8 jours Hélène
oui voilà donc c'est pas comme si ils
auront une grande contribution
percutante à faire au cours de ces 8
jours là et avec je pense 4 questions au
total dans ces 8 jours donc on pourrait
très bien dire pour maintenant on passe
notre tour mais le problème se posera à
nouveau lors de la reprise après Noël
alors on ne fait que reporter le
problème je suis pas certaine qu'on
aurait le temps d'ici là de régler la
question on n'a pas le temps de régler
la question
la question du serment
je suis pas certaine qu'on aurait le
temps d'ici à la prochaine reprise c'est
ce que je veux dire mais je suis d'une
part je suis très sensible aux arguments
de Michel dire qu'il faut en revenir je
comprends mais en même temps de tenir
son bout ça peut être que ça ferait
justement mettre suffisamment de
pression pour que le gouvernement se
sente obligé de faire procéder tout ça à
la quatrième vitesse pour que justement
on est adopté le projet de loi si ce
n'est pas pour le retour après Noël
quelques temps après où j'en ai Émilie
devant ce combat des trois députés du
Parti québécois je pense qu'une
tentation pour les trois députés de
faire un coup d'éclat parce que sinon
c'est trop députés sur 125 à l'Assemblée
nationale qui comme on disait justement
rend pas beaucoup l'occasion de se faire
entendre donc il y a peut-être une façon
pour eux de d'essayer d'avoir
essentiellement l'attention sur cet
enjeu là à l'extérieur de l'Assemblée
nationale plutôt qu'à l'intérieur c'est
peut-être ça la tentation
tout ce qui est dans leur tête en ce
moment on sait aussi il y a quelques il
y a quelques semaines qui voulaient que
la carte essentiellement présente une
motion plutôt qu'un projet de loi c'est
peut-être l'occasion aussi de dire si
vous faites un projet de loi faites le
rapidement sinon peut-être une motion
pour nous laisser siège au parlement
donc je pense qu'il y a peut-être une
chance qui essaie d'utiliser ça pour
avoir essentiellement plus d'attention
que s'ils font juste essentiellement se
faire jurer et se joindre si c'était une
session parlementaire de plus que budget
je pense que la question se posera
autrement mais on va voir on va bien
voir demain ce qui est comment ils vont
naviguer ça ok huit jours on va revoir
le calendrier il y a il y a des choses
déjà télégraphiées projette de loi un
Michel c'est pour limiter tous les
tarifs ça a déjà été dit à 3 %. donc il
y a une mise à jour économique le 8 puis
fin de session le 9 sur le discours
d'ouverture aussi qui doit être fait
alors ça laisse pas de temps pour un
projet de loi avant Noël il faut quand
même le dire parce qu'il y a un projet
de loi qui doit passer c'est celui qui
va limiter les des augmentations de
tarif gouvernementaux alors dans la
réalité des choses oui où ils acceptent
de venir si jamais en sachant qu'il va y
avoir un projet de loi parce que tout le
monde est d'accord là-dessus ou bien non
mais il rentrera en janvier je sais pas
s'ils sont payés en attendant par
exemple ça c'est une question à poser
je sais pas on n'a jamais est-ce que
vous avez un doute
là-dessus je ne sais pas
qu'on avait déterminé qu'il l'était mais
moi aussi
très bien
premier résultat 2-30
quand même la politique de Madame jolie
j'en ai parlé que Jean-François assez
longuement tout à l'heure mais là c'est
comme si on mettait en ordre notre
vision pas mal au diapason de ce qui a
été dire Washington depuis des années
cette stratégie ado Pacifique Michel C
ça tient la route c'est c'est un
éclaircissement un peu
on a mis beaucoup trop d'enfants sur la
Chine
avec Kim Canada en oubliant tout le
reste il y a des puissances économiques
dans cette région là l'Indonésie en est
une la Malaisie en est une il y a
plusieurs qui sont des pays beaucoup
plus proche de nous qui ont les liens
entre autres par le commonwaltérieur des
évidemment qui font que on a plus de
liens et plus et moins d'animosité avec
des pays comme ça donc s'il n'y a pas de
mal à lire investir là-bas plutôt que
toujours en Chine Hélène
oui effectivement et j'ai hâte de voir
aussi comment ça va s'opérationnaliser
et tout ça c'est un peu ce comme un trou
de bain en fait c'est une politique pour
contourner la Chine la Chine étant le
trou dans tout ça on en parle peu en
fait trois pages mais dans ce document
mais dans le fond le document c'est le
fantôme du document c'est la Chine c'est
quoi faire pour la contourner on a vu
Ottawa
redresser un peu les chines par exemple
sur l'achat de minières peut être par
les Chinois qui qui œuvrent dans le
domaine le plus critique des minéraux
critiques donc on voit certaines
positions qui se durcissent du Canada
mais c'est à la longue on va voir si on
fait ce que l'on prétend vouloir faire
Émilie conclusion là-dessus lorsque de
l'échange qui est beaucoup circuler
qu'on a vu filmer au G20 entre Justin
Trudeau et présidentielle une des choses
qu'on s'est dit c'est que semblait qu'il
semblait avoir peu de respect pour le
Canada parce qu'on était parfois vu à la
remorque des autres pays certainement du
G7 et du G20 je pense que c'est un peu
ça qui ressort dans cette politique là
c'est à dire que elle est très alignée
sur ce que je fais des États-Unis ce qui
fait ailleurs en Occident c'est juste
qu'on l'a fait après tout le monde donc
essentiellement il y a pas beaucoup
rapidement comme ça ils sont pas avoir
beaucoup de nouveautés on sent mes
essentiellement suivre ce que ce que les
autres pays occidentaux ont déjà décidé
de faire par rapport à la Chine ce qui
est pas nécessairement une mauvaise
chose c'est juste que on n'est pas très
original là-dedans il y a pas
d'originalité très bien Véronique prince
qui nous écoutent on l'a salu nous dit
oui ils sont payés les députés
élu payer mais si j'ai ou pas c'est
assurance
et là de Michel Émilie merci beaucoup
bonne soirée au revoir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI